now when you play board games or card
games around a table with friends you
have all these interesting social
dynamics like trust and betrayal and
deception and all these things the way
the players are interacting and out
thinking one another you don't really
get that in online video games so so how
can we capture that that led us to
rebels within where your villagers
around the table and you're trying to
figure out who the werewolves are and
you're sitting there it's like playing a
card game but in a way that was never
possible before here worlds within is
set in the village of galliston and
galliston has a bit of a problem is
infested with werewolves and so every
night the villagers get together to
figure out who among them are these
horrible werewolves acting with these
vicious depredations and they are trying
to figure out who to condemn to their
doom
there's things that VR replicates for
example the whisper feature in our game
you can do that in real life whisper to
the person next to you it really lets
you bring that game table experience
into VR you know into this new
technology all these social cues these
these physical presence elements these
ambient movements that you make while
you're at the table reading your towels
and your pantomimes and your giveaways
all of those translate almost perfectly
into VR and that was a perfect fit into
the social deduction game that we
eventually found ourselves making with
werewolf and those friends have become
other towns folk villagers in this
medieval village together sitting around
the table seeing everybody's body
language talking to each other playing
social deduction style games and having
a great time and are you around the
world or next door one of the features I
really like to use in the game is the
monologue feature and most players stand
up and they deliver a very heartfelt
diatribe on why you shouldn't vote for
them or why you should vote for this guy
usually I like to use it just to shut
everyone up and I'll cross my arms
standing up silently and just shake my
head at redstone there's a long
multiplayer history a lot of different
types of multiplayer games and what VR
brings to us now a new way to let
players interact with each other so
wearables within this is social around
the table experience that's very
discussion and personality they
we're working on things that give other
types of player interaction in VR and we
have a lot of exciting ideas and expect
a lot of great things to come out of
here in the next few years